Tyga detained by police in LA the Rack  City rapper was seen being hauled away  by authorities Tuesday night after  leaving Avenue nightclub in hollywood  now see me coming down see me coming run  tonight you like bmxing a spokesperson  for the LAPD tells ET during a traffic  stop police noticed that Tyga only had  paper license plates on his Mercedes  g-wagen an eyewitness tells ET Tyga did  not appear upset as he was pulled over  he was spotted wearing a bright hoodie  and flashy jewelry as he was escorted to  a police car due to excessive paparazzi  law enforcement transported the 27 year  old rapper to the police station where  he took a field sobriety test and passed  Tyga was later released and cited for a  minor traffic violation  you